what's then to talk to are guests about
Ben Barry former director of British
Army staff UK Ministry of Defense hello
to you thanks for joining us on the
program this morning we saw that
absolute tragedy uh over the weekend
when an apartment block with 2 000
people inside was targeted uh by the
Russians what more do we know
well I think we know that most of them
actually got out but sadly there's been
some casualties and this is all part of
Russia's campaign to attack Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure power Heating
and uh the road the railways some of the
cruise missiles they're firing are
pretty accurate but at the moment they
seem to be firing a lot less accurate
ballistic missiles and obviously Naval
cruise missiles so it isn't surprising
I'm afraid
can attacks like this be described as
war crimes
well that's that's not an easy question
to Art to answer if they're actually
aimed at the
um a military Target
and they've gone off course that's
probably not a war crime but if they've
actually been deliberately aimed at the
Ukrainian civil population for example
if it were deliberately aimed at that
apartment block there would be a case to
answer for a war crime
me more generally than if you would
please sir about Vladimir Putin saying
his special military operation I'm
quoting him directly is developing
within the framework of the plan does
that mean
The Tide is changing in this war
well the tides changed several times it
changed in spring when the Russians
failed to attack Kiev and withdrew from
it turning their main effort to the
donbass it's changed the game with the
successful Ukrainian counter-offensive
at uh kharkiv and more recently with the
counter-offensive at Curson it seems at
the moment that Russia just doesn't have
the offensive combat power on the ground
to be able to recapture substantive
territory hence much of the front lines
turning into attrition rather like a
first World War battlefield
you talked about
um how he's changed his top commander on
the ground several times
um done that again over the last week or
so every time that happens we seem to
see even bloodier more deadly attacks do
you think that is
um each of them trying to prove that
they are more uh successful at trying to
win this war than the previous one
well that may well be the case k
um of course the the previous Commander
remains in the chain of command but
General grassimov who's the overall
Russian forces Chief has now taken
charge of the whole operation whether
though he can think of any new strategic
gambits that will unlock the battlefield
uh that's a difficult question to to
answer because of course the War Began
badly with considerable overall over
optimism displayed by Russia at a high
level of strategic and Military
incompetence whether he can make the
Russian forces much more incompetent but
much more competent I should say is an
open question I think
who's winning this war at the moment
well yes they they still seem to have a
difficulty properly coordinating
combined arms for example even with the
addition of the the Wagner private
military company they're finding it very
difficult to concentrate sufficient
thoughts at a decisive point to break
through whereas on the other hand
Ukraine's fighting a strong defensive
battle and continuing to use its U.S
supplied High Mars rocket launchers and
other Western weapons as well as its
Special Forces and partisans to attack
Russian positions throughout their depth
so the chances of a Russian breakthrough
in the near future I think are pretty
low uh um including the promise of uh 14
um Challenger 2 tanks from the British
government are going to hear more on
that from the defense secretary in the
House of Commons later on today uh we're
speaking to the Lord done it last week
he says that's nowhere near enough what
do you think
well Ukraine's been very clear it said
it wants a minimum of 300 modern Western
tanks uh 14 British tanks and about a
dozen Polish tanks that polish has
Poland has in principle said it's
delivered is only a small proportion of
that that's two companies of tanks at
most whereas what Poland's asking for is
about six battalions worth of tax now
there are a lot of modern Western tanks
in Europe there's 2 000 odd leopard two
tanks which is the sort that Poland's
supplying and it ought to be not too
difficult for European NATO Nations that
have leopard too the club together to
find about 400 leopard tanks
there's an issue though isn't there with
these leopard tanks perhaps you could
explain that um to us it's a German
license and so there's a sticking point
yes they're German built and under the
terms in which they were sold to the
country's concern Germany has a veto on
them being sold to a third party now
Germany of course is a nation that has a
degree of institutional pacifism built
into its Constitution and in the past
it's refused to supply weapons to an
active theater theater of war although
Chancellor Schultz shortly after the War
Began in his speech saying that Germany
was at a zeitant wender a turning point
uh implied that Germany would become
much more
um assertive in exporting weapons to
Ukraine they have of course exported
weapons from anti-tank weapons to the
recent declaration Declaration of Nevada
battalion's worth of martyr infantry
fighting vehicles but there still seems
to be a degree of political and
institutional reluctance in Germany but
we will see shortly there's to be a NATO
um Nation Summit of the contact group
with net with Ukraine including all the
nations uh Beyond NATO and that's to
coordinate our arms and equipment
supplies and deliveries to Ukraine and
it may be that Poland and the UK have
both acted in a way to encourage Germany
to remove the restrictions on the
exports of leopard two tax sure but to
that end Christine and brecht I think
I'm right in saying the defense minister
is basically on our last legs when it
comes to her political position and
there's a lot of criticism internally uh
for her lack of action what sort of
challenges do you think that that
political disharmony in Germany what
sort of challenges do you think that
could play out in the battlefield in
Ukraine
well if Germany uh makes difficulties
about this um approach to sending
leopard two tanks to
um Ukraine Ukraine will have less combat
less combat power than it would like we
need to be clear that the reason Ukraine
said it wants 300 tanks and six or seven
hundred infantry fighting Vehicles as
well as another 500 additional houses is
so it can build up heavy armored or
mechanized formations to mount a
strategic counter-offensive this year to
evict Russia from Ukraine if if no one
supplies more than the current
25 odd modern Western tanks that the
British and the Pope the polls have
declared Ukraine is going to find that a
lot more difficult
okay good to talk to you thanks for
explaining that to us this morning thank
you awesome